hot breath yeah and and finding your
voice
is something all comics strive for
is it when when because 20 years in
you know in 12 years seriously but like
when did you think or was there a
certain
bit to where you felt like you were
starting to kind of open up a new realm
of your comedy and
into your voice
um well i feel like twitter helped me
out a whole bunch
because it was really a place to put
thoughts up and not care
like at first i didn't even understand
faves and retweets
um so i was just putting all kinds of
thoughts up on
twitter and not even in joke format and
then just realizing people
had similar um situations like that then
i was
then that made me realize oh this is
probably something i could talk about so
something so
niche or niche or whatever you're like
no a lot of people know what you're
talking about and you can do this
um sometimes on stage it won't hit but
there'll be an audience that likes it
and they'll find you once you
uh do that uh
but then the i think i had one bit
where i was i took the train and this
guy was like
i don't know the the way he approached
me was so weird
and then i treated it as if it was a
real conversation and i felt like when i
did that on stage
without doing a setup punch line and
just doing
bits as dialogue and being
just telling the story through my point
of view i felt like that was the first
time where i
was like i think now i get this i know
how to do this and that was like a year
in
when i moved to new york i felt more
like
there's a lot of time there's a lot of
times where i'm just like oh i think i
get
how to do this stand-up thing and then i
do a set and i'm like me okay maybe you
don't but
i felt like there is a time when you're
like oh
that's very that is definitely that's me
and i think i figured it my way of being
me on stage
without trying really hard and it felt
effortless
that's where that i had a joke like that
but i didn't do it in my set
but yeah or in the album yeah that is
that is
a good note though of like you weren't
going for setup punch you were going for
like but what is sarah's point of view
here
and that really started to crack open
that new writing
yeah well not that i would ever teach a
class but i think sometimes for classes
like or
just for comedy i think a lot of comics
when you first start out you're always
thinking about like i need to write a
joke i need to write a joke but
honestly like having you ever had that
guy at work or that friend that just
tells you their story
of what they did that morning and you're
laughing hysterically because they're
telling you
their what their problem solving skills
are in their head or what they're
thinking and you're like that's so funny
so
i remember a lot of times in like new
york i was like i'm not going to go up
and try to write a joke i'm just going
to
tell you about my day and then i felt
like that was more
satisfying than and then finding
bits that way then right trying to
figure out like what
set up punchline can i come up with now
yes i definitely started like one-liners
first
and not way less conversational we just
had cal canada on here and he
he mentioned the same thing where he
first like learned joke structure
and it's kind of like learning the rules
before you break them in a sense
so it's like yeah but it's that's what
i've learned in interviewing over 200
comics
is like there's no one way
it's like everyone has their own unique
way at the end of the day
yeah i feel like like a good example of
someone that does that really well
is naper ghatsi like he doesn't really
feel like he's giving you a set up
punchline all he's really doing is
telling you
what is going through his mind and
that's where the jokes come
and that's how how i feel like where you
find out
who you are on stage is like just talk
about the weird that's going
through your mind or your obsessive
thoughts and
i think people will relate to you or
find it interesting hot breath